quand le jazz est quand le jazz est
Java la Java s'en va IL y a de l'e dans
l'il dans le gaz entre le jazz et la
Java chaque jour un peu Plus IL y a le
jazz qui sst alors la rage Au cur la
fille, c'est la
m taille sous sa jupe fendue elle écrase
sa gauloise et s'en va dans la rue quand
le jaz est quand le
est le jav jav
va IL et a de l'eau dans l' IL et a de
l'eau dans
Le cas entre le jazz et Java quand
j'écoute un solo de patrie IL et au
Java qui rale Au nom de la patrie mais
quand je dis Bravo
l'accordéoniste c'est le Ja mque moi
traître raciste quand le jazz est
quand le jazz
est-ce ha ha
va IL y a de l'e dans l'air IL a l'eau
dans
l'entre jazz et Java pour Moi
c'est du pareil Au mme Je chante la
bastille et je
blouse pour Moi Java dans le fond c'est
tout quand vous voyez Java home
mais quand le jazz c'est quand
est ha ha s'en
va IL et a de l' l' IL et a de l'eau
dans entre le jazz et la java jazz et
Java copain doit pouvoir se faire pour
qu'il en soit un s bien Je partage en
Frère Je donne chass de pied pour marquer
ils sont
tempo et Je donne la Java mes mains pour
Il y en a deux et j'ai le Java
mes mains pour le bas de son
deux